is there intelligent life i'll go even
further is there life at all on other
planets the one argument that drives me
the craziest is this one they say
michael
it's just it's just probable it's just
probability in modernity we're told
we're not we're not special we not look
there's probably a zillion other of us
and my only point is maybe that's true
but we have no evidence we have no
reason to believe that that we're not
special michael's wrong on this the
argument he dismisses the argument that
comes from just that the vastness of the
universe is what tells us that there's
probably life on it that's not only a
good argument it's actually decisive
and the propagandists on the anti-alien
side have never come up with a good
answer to it you sit on a throne of lies
so michael says well there's no reason
to think that there is life you know
we've been to one planet all of us this
one
the only planet we've ever been to has
life on it we know that there are
trillions of other planets
on what basis can we possibly assume
that none of the other ones are anything
like this one if you say that then
you're the one that has to bring the
evidence boom roasted